heute wurde in hameln ein
kindergeburtstag mit 30 gästen aufgelöst
ein kindergeburtstag
hier feierten und sie sehen das bild
gleich mario und vanessa ihren neunten
geburtstag hier sind sie noch glücklich
ja und dann wurden sie von den nachbarn
vertiefen die polizei rückte an
gleichzeitig versuchten sich kinder noch
in einer toilette zu verstecken aber
dann wurde alles aufgelöst unser
reporter stephan siewering der hat mit
der familie gesprochen und stephan steht
jetzt dort in hameln vor dem haus wo
alles passiert ist passiert
stefan erklär uns mal was ist da hinter
dir in diesem haus abgelaufen wie es
dazu gekommen dass die polizei ernsthaft
angerückt ist beim kindergeburtstag
ja wir waren eben bei der familie wir
haben mit ihm gesprochen
die waren noch sichtlich unter schock
offenbaren nachbarn angerufen und die
verfassen
die kinder sagen sie mir dann gerade
dabei gewesen den geburtstagskerzen auf
der torte auszublasen
da wäre die polizei mit zehn mann
gekommen und hätte quasi alle räume
durchsucht und so sind alten geweint
werden weg gelaufen also die waren noch
sichtlich unter schock die beiden
zwillinge die da ihren neunten
geburtstag gefeiert haben schrecklich
das zu hören vor allem bei geburtstag
etwas schönes und erinnerungswürdige
sein sollen aber was hat das jetzt für
konsequenzen für die eltern
ich habe mit dem landkreis gesprochen
die haben ungefähr 150 euro wie das
kosten pro erwachsenen der da anwesend
ist
möglicherweise werden auch kinder
belangt die nach dem wir als ich den
besten blätter geklärt aber auf jeden
fall muss jeder erwachsene daran diesen
250 euro bezahlen
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bild schaut euch hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren